hey there welcome back today I'm going
to look at another very old exam this
one is an MIT entrance exam from 1869
and I found this on the MIT archives
website so I'll put the link to that in
the description and it might be worth
checking it out yourself because they
actually have a lot of they're really
old exams and some solutions there as
well now the MIT entrance exam seems
like it was introduced in 1869 although
the school first had classes starting in
1865 so there was actually a few years
there where no entrance exam was
required and students were just expected
to have a proper education to get in
this exam that I found covers English
algebra geometry and arithmetic but I'm
just going to look at the algebra
section and an effort to keep this video
kind of short and also because I already
looked at some old fashioned arithmetic
questions in my last video
there was a photo on the website of a
class from 1873 and it's likely that the
people in this photo would have been the
ones to set this exam that I'm going to
look through so that's kind of
interesting to know I will say and I do
take a bit of caution and saying this
but I sort of think this algebra section
is surprisingly easy I think it's less
to do with you know being a really
competitive exam and more to do we're
just showing that you do have some sort
of basic education in something like
algebra and you're ready to go off to
MIT I think it's useful to keep in mind
that back in the 19th century it was not
that common for people to be getting
past say 8th grade or something like
that or should be getting full proper
education so for schools like MIT they
had a very limited pool of students that
they needed to attract to their college
for them to be successful so I think
this idea that getting into one of these
top schools being highly competitive for
many qualified students is a bit new to
sort of our generation and looking back
at the 19th century
that probably wasn't the case so let's
just have a look at it so this is the
algebra section here and I'll go through
the questions but just at a glance at
them here you probably might recognize
how to do most of them already if you do
have a math education or a math
background we're just doing things like
simplifying an expression multiplying
something out reducing something to its
simplest form simplifying solving
algebra and these are all kind of basic
equations I think these are the sorts of
things you would probably see today in
something like eighth grade or yeah
definitely within high school math
education it's also interesting to note
that the language too still holds true
today so this exam has aged pretty well
I think it's because they don't go too
much into context and try to explain
anything too deeply but you know words
like multiply reduce to as lowest terms
simplify you know that's I think that
can't really age these are just the
basics of math and these are still how
we would write math questions today so I
understand what I'm being asked for and
all of these questions part one you've
got this expression and it's got a bunch
of E's in it now I was initially fooled
into thinking that this was you know
like e as in like 2.7 something
something but it's just a variable
they've said e is equal to 8 I don't
know if that's the worst engineers an
approximation for e ever but it actually
makes this question kind of simple you
just need to sub you know 8 and here so
we've got like 8 minus the square root
of a plus 1 that's 9 8 minus the cube
root of 8 which is going to be 2 and
then square root of 4 that's going to be
let's just work some of these out and
I'll do them over here
eight minus three plus two plus eight
minus two well actually that's just
going to be six times the square root of
four that's going to be times two so
this part here will be adding twelve
eight minus five so that's going to be 3
plus twelve we're going to have 15 as
our answer there I guess I'm kind of
exposing my own abilities with some
arithmetic and algebra here hopefully
I'm not doing too bad of a job question
to simplify the following expression
remove the brackets and click like terms
so let's do it sort of layer by layer
our first layer will be these curly
brackets in here so we'll get rid of
those two having here B plus 2 a minus B
minus a plus B then we'll get rid of our
next layer of brackets we'll have 3a
minus B minus 2 a plus B plus a minus B
let's simplify this
okay I'm going to plus a so then put
that there so I think what we'll end up
with here in the end will be 2 a minus B
Christian the 3 multiply this expression
here by this one and divide the product
by a plus B now a bad way to approach
this question would be to do the
complete multiplication first and to
completely expand you know what you're
going to get a few multiply this in
brackets by this expression here and
then trying to divide that answer by a
plus B that's not going to be that
Pleasant instead what I would recommend
is to try to factor out an a plus B from
either of these two expressions which
will mean you know won't have to divide
by it afterwards
so let's try and take an A+ be out of
this one here
I will factor out an A plus B so if it's
possible what we're going to have in
this bracket would be an A that gives us
our a squared we're going to have a B
squared but we want to have a -3 so try
this and yep that will give us a squared
minus 3 a B plus a B minus 3 B squared
that's the correct factorization there
now we just want to take this multiply
it by 3 a squared plus a B minus B
squared which was that expression here
and don't forget we want we're dividing
out this a plus B so we effected it so
that we can get rid of it which means
we're just actually multiplying this
bracket by this bracket here to get our
answer that's going to give us 3a cubed
plus okay I'll do this term next a
squared B minus B squared a name is Tim
that will give us three a cubed we've
got a squared B here and here that's
going to give us minus eight a squared B
lose our B squared a so we're going to
have minus 1 and minus 3 and lastly our
3b cubed so that's our answer to 3 right
there Christian for reduced the
following fraction to its lowest terms I
just want us to simplify this okay so
let's try and extract whatever we can
out of here if we're you just block off
this I've got an X in both terms on the
top line and that's X to the 6 plus a
squared X to the cubed Y so what I could
do is take and X cubed out and then we'd
have another X cubed plus a squared Y
that would be our new top line and
that's I think as condensed as we can
make the top line the numerator so what
would be great is if we could take this
X cubed plus a squared Y also out of the
bottom line out of their denominator so
let's try and do that so I'm trying to
take that out of the second line and
what would I be left with and actually
I'd have an X cubed - this is going to
be the difference of two squares because
we only want to get two terms another a
squared Y alright so that should give us
our denominator meaning that we can
cancel out these two and our final most
simplified answer would be X cubed over
X cubed minus a squared Y all right
let's move on to question five we want
to simplify this expression here so we
have this in brackets divided by the set
of Records here
these two sets of records are the same
except that this one is Plus in the
middle and this one is - to be able to
add fractions or to subtract fractions
we want them to have common denominators
so I'm going to essentially take the
side times up by a plus B take this side
and times by a minus B and that will
convert them to having the same
denominators so that we can actually add
them it'll look like this a plus B
we want to divide by the snakes thing
and I'm going to do the same to that but
keep in mind that dividing by a fraction
is the same as multiplying by that
fractions reciprocal which means
swapping the numerator and denominator
so I'm going to multiply it by the
reciprocal of this but converted to have
the same denominator so it's going to
look like this
we can do some canceling now we can
cancel this whole line with this one
here our answer will just be this on top
of this but they probably want us to
expand that out so we'll do that kind of
quickly
okay now we want to cancel some terms
and we can write our final answer as
being two a squared plus two B squared
over 4a B and in fact you could take a
two out of all of these so we'd get rid
of the to get rid of the two this one
here would become a two instead of
before there's your answer
so question six we want to solve for
this expression here and what I want to
do is get rid of these things on the
bottom that's going to make it a lot
easier so let's just do it one by one
first of all we're going to get rid of
the two on the bottom so I'm going to
times each term by 2 which would get rid
of that we would get a 2 on the top here
which would actually be like changing
listen to a 4 and likewise this would
change into an 8 next step we want to
get rid of the 4 times every term by for
the would get rid of this would put a 4
up on this line and it would change this
to a 2 alright last step we want to get
rid of this 2 times every term by 2
it's going to get rid of that that 4 is
going to change to an 8 tip this isn't a
missing we're going to get a times 2 for
everything they're now on paper let's
just write that out expand it so 8 times
3x minus 4 24 X minus 4 times 8 32 minus
2 times 6 12 X it's a double negative
here we're going to add 10 is equal to
3x minus 1 okay click to like terms 24 X
minus 12x just going to be 12x minus 22
equal to 3x minus 1 get our X's on to
the side and our constants over there
we're going to get 12 minus 3 9 X is
equal to 21
X is going to be equal to 21 over 9 or
that can be written as 7 over 3 there
you go and our last one is question 7
this is two variables two unknowns with
two equations so it's like whatever it's
called simultaneous equations or
something so what we're going to do is
select one of them and rearrange it to
get an expression for one of the
variables so let's just take this one
here I'm going to rearrange this for X
so X would be equal to 11 plus 3y over 4
I'm going to sub that value of X into
this equation here I know there are
several types of several ways of solving
problems like this this might be a bad
way but I don't know it just seems like
an easy way for me to do right now
considering I haven't done these
problems for a while
I'm taking that four and multiplying
every 10 by it because I think that's
easier than dividing those numbers by
four okay subtract this that's going to
be 19 and that would be y equals 19 cool
now we just need to sub that back in for
X and find out what X would be it would
be 11 plus 3 times 19 that would bring
the total up there 268 divide it by 4 X
would be equal to 17 all right well
there's the exam solved for you but
maybe you didn't need me to solve it for
you because I don't know I sort of think
this exam is surprisingly easy like I
said before it is kind of eighth grade
algebra so maybe getting into MIT in the
19th century was easier than passing
eighth grade today I don't know maybe
times have changed a little bit I would
say you know do keep in mind that maybe
this exam didn't serve the same purpose
that entrance exams do now which had to
like really narrow down the amount of
people applying maybe this was more
representative of the fact that these
colleges were really you know upper
crust institutions and they had a very
limited pool of students from from which
you know to get applicants in the first
place so they probably you know wasn't
in their best interest to be turning
away a lot of students at this stage so
thanks for watching and leave any
thoughts in the comments I will likely
attempt some of the other sections maybe
the geometry section are in a later
video thanks to brilliant org for
sponsoring me to make this video if you
want to brush up on your own algebra
skills then you can work through
brilliants course exploring the
foundations of algebra and logic without
any rote memorization you can head to
brilliant org slash
tibbie's and sign up for free and the
first 200 people to do so get 20% off an
annual premium subscription if you're
still looking for a gift this holiday
season then maybe consider gifting
someone a premium subscription thanks
also go to those who support me on
patreon